-I'm happy everyone's here.
You know, today's Friday,
and that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and of course I send out
thank you notes.
And I was...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...running a bit --
I'm running a bit behind today,
so I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind,
I would like to write out
my weekly
thank you notes right now.
Is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good Friday crowd.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
He's kind of half smiling.
-Wow.
♪♪
-Thank you,
March Madness brackets,
for being approximately
one hour of fun
followed by three weeks
of slow motion disappointment.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you,
daylight savings time,
or as I like to call you,
microwave clock
appreciation day.
Yeah, we're back!
-We're back.
Whoo!
-Thank you, giant Joro spiders
that can float in the air,
for still only being
the second most terrifying
airborne experience.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?
Come on.
What?
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, poster for the new
Pixar movie "Turning Red,"
for looking like Bernie sanders
if he went on "Hot Ones."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Oh, it's the bomb!
Don't give me the bomb!"
-Thank you, White House,
for sending Kamala Harris
to Poland and Romania this week,
or as she put it,
"Sorry, did I not clap enough
at the State of the Union?"
[ Applause ]
Why am I...?
-[ Chuckles ]
-Thank you,
new Obi-Wan Kenobi trailer,
for not going by your original
name, "The Sandalorian."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Thinker.
That's a thinker.
-That's a thinker.
It's worth it.
-So worth it.
-Thank you, premium gasoline,
for being Fiji water
for my car.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.
-Lot of money.
-Just for this?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Still cheaper that Fiji water.
[ Light laughter ]
-Thank you, wallet phone case,
for keeping
my credit cards safe,
which is good to know
that if I lose my phone,
I lose everything.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are my thank you notes.